stick around at the end of this video
where we'll look at all the connections
between more day-out
and the Native American legend it's
based on the Wendigo this video is
sponsored by [ __ ] TV and welcome back to
things you missed in this video we'll be
breaking down everything you missed in
offering the new episode of more Deo on
Crips TV for those who aren't aware more
Deo is a serialization of the 2017 short
film of the same name in which a
cannibal in the woods is transformed
into a monster controlled by the more
day-out we later find out in a crypt
announcement video that the creature who
appeared in that short is merely a scout
a proxy of the Queen so the new episode
opens as many Crypt productions do with
a little bit of gore this character Dan
gets his fingers chopped off by a masked
man simply known as the butcher at first
I assumed that the woman hiding out
behind the tree Linda was his girlfriend
or something however and Dan has a ring
on his finger and she does not we'll see
if that ends up being a significant part
of the story or if it's just an extra
detail the butcher is carrying a book
and a newspaper with him and both
contain important details
he starts by referencing the book which
we can quickly see based on the art
style is the crypts home the book
prominently featured in sunny found the
cult that contains rituals and then may
use to turn themselves into monsters the
butcher uses the book to find the ritual
site and carry out the ritual he's able
to get the Queen more Deo to appear and
seems to be excited to transform into a
monster yelling out things like I'm
ready and please make me one of you
however things don't go as he expected
the Queen bites off three of his fingers
on his right hand the same fingers that
he removed from Dan at the beginning of
the episode it is as it was told by the
victim in the original more Deo short
film there's a price to pay for eating
flesh so the butcher is cursed with
permanent finger guns for life which is
really only another minute or so because
the Queen more Deo snaps his neck the
butcher appears to have followed the
ritual so why wasn't he turned into a
monster let's look back at the book it
shows imagery of human flesh along with
an open mouth and the words hunger
desperation and offering there's also an
illustration of the hooded scout from
the original short film that the series
is based on so let's look there for more
clues that one also has a cannibal
eating flesh but in his case he appears
to be eating in order to survive listen
to this dialogue
you are all hungry there's no shame in
that
the butcher in the new episode isn't
doing it because he's hungry he's doing
it to try to become a monster hunger
desperation and offering these are the
requirements that must be met in order
for the transformation to take place
just as Roger had to meet certain
requirements in the third season of
Sonny family calls that wraps up the
mystery of the butcher but we still
don't know why the other two human
characters Dan and Linda are out in the
woods as well
when in doubt when watching Crypt TV
stuff you always got to look for paper
speaking of which you should sign up for
the Crypt newsletter I mean it doesn't
actually come on paper it's an email
with updates on the Crypt monster
universe special access merge drops and
insider info it's free just look for my
link in the description anyway the
newspaper headline tells us what we need
to know going forward into this season
there are three missing Girl Scouts
Angela Nancy and the other one Jen I
told you always got to look for the
papers this is just pure speculation but
Nancy looks like she could be possibly
related to Linda the girl that we saw
hiding from the butcher my guess is that
Linda and Dan are out searching for the
missing girls the name of this newspaper
is the Mohawk ledger which ties into
another trip series mohawk which takes
place in a tiny New York town in a
modern setting however more Dayo takes
place about 40 years before that if you
pause on the newspaper right before the
blood hits it you can see the date
October 29 1979 that also places this
just two days before Halloween which may
or may not be significant once we get
into those later episodes in addition to
the search for those missing girls
there's also another clue pointing
toward the possible crossover with
another Crypt TV franchise this symbol
carved on the fallen tree doesn't match
up with the symbol of more day out but
rather the icon of the verge another
forest dwelling monster and a protector
of good children against evil the
inclusion of the birch symbol could just
be a small promotion for the birch which
is getting a series of its own this year
but it could also mean that the birch is
in the same territory as more day out
and may appear to the aid of the missing
girls if more day out comes hunting if
that happens
expect to see a huge showdown between
Moore Deo
Laberge more Deo is based off of the
mythological creature known as the
Wendigo the Wendigo isn't Algonquian
legend associated with famine greed and
cannibalism this episode reflects those
theme by introducing the butcher a
product of greed who's willing to resort
to cannibalism not to survive but simply
to gain more power the one to go is a
demonic creature with a humanoid form
and the head of a stag its hunger can
never be satisfied so it's always
looking for new victims making it a
metaphorical tale the Algonquian people
would tell their young to discourage
greedy behavior it roams forests in the
northern Atlantic coast in North America
which is why the territory of Moore Deo
resides in Mohawk New York tribal
members would sometimes perform a
ceremony during times of famine in order
to discourage taboo behaviors the
ceremony involved dancing around a drum
while wearing horned masks which may
have something to do with the masks worn
by the butcher in this episode some
legends say that the Wendigo has an
effect on the entire region that it
inhabits causing evil spirits to possess
locals there are many different versions
of the legend the only way to find out
what creepy twist strip TV puts on this
native folk tale is to subscribe to
their Channel and catch new episodes of
more Deo and other crypt Muenster
universe videos every Friday don't
forget to sign up to that newsletter to
stay up to date on even more great
content and as always I'll see you in
the next one assuming we both survive